many of us have started holiday shopping
and it's supposed to be a fun time of
giving but it can be ruined by grinch's
stealing from you either through cyber
scams or right in the store kathy stokes
is the director of fraud prevention at
aarp good morning kathy you've got a lot
of great information let's just jump
into it
first of all the online shopping it's
big what should online shoppers be aware
of when purchasing gifts this year
especially this time of year scammers
are quite aware that we're doing a lot
of our holiday shopping online
so the things we have to be
watchful for are
fake advertisements online
emails with links texts with links uh
your best bet is you know choose the
retailer you want to visit online
go to your web browser and type that
exact web address in that will prevent
you from going to a cloned website or
even a website that the intent of which
is for you to visit there so that
malicious software gets onto your device
and that's where they're trying to steal
your credentials your logins even to
bank accounts
gift cards big go-to gift choice
uh what's uh what's the awareness
anything for buyers to really watch out
for even buying them in the store you
know scammers do go into these brick and
mortar stores they go over that big
shiny rack that we all see they grab
some cards off of there flip them over
expose the pen take pictures cover the
pin back up put them back on the rack
and then we come in nonetheless pick up
a card purchase it as soon as we
purchase it that scammer knows because
they have a computer program monitoring
it and they drain those funds oh my gosh
so to avoid that
best thing i would say is go to the
retailer online
you know typing in that web address and
buy it directly or if you are going to
go into a brick and mortar store take a
real close look at those cards before
you buy them make sure they don't look
like they've been manipulated okay
how safe is it to use those peer-to-peer
apps like venmo and cash app to pay for
things not safe to use them to purchase
products or
send money to people you don't know
that's not what they're intended for
they're intended for you to be able to
split a dinner bill with your friends or
pay the babysitter anything beyond that
you're at real risk because if you end
up sending money fraudulently you're not
going to get that money back and there's
really there's nothing you can do about
it
kathy says that more fraud prevention
information is available at aarp.org
fraud watch network
there we go there's the address and if
you've been a victim of fraud well you
can call their fraud fighters hotline
that's
three
877-9083
six zero and that is no fun this time of
year everybody's in the holiday spirit
you know and you wanna give and receive
and then you've gotta deal with fraud
and somebody getting into your bank
account your credit card account it's
just no it's a nightmare or maybe even
ransomware if you're clicking on you
know links that are suspicious yeah so
i've uh i've had conversations with my
parents once in a while about hey do you
think this is an okay deal do you think
that and they'll read me off whatever
they see online or something like no
steer clear it's not worth it stick with
what you know go with what's bona fide
don't mess around too good to be true it
is
right you know in this time of year when
we're all in a giving mood that's when
the grinches come in yeah yeah they like
to steal our fun yeah
all right